so macy gray i think went on pierce  morgan and said that women are women and  trans women are essentially not  biological women so and then she went on  the  was it the view not the view um she went  on the good morning today show or  something like that and then said that  she  learned from all of her mistakes  and she's now says that whoever  identifies as a woman is a woman it was  it was also like the worst apology ever  like i feel like that was very messy  gray of her to be like look i probably  don't want to say this but they made me  say this let me just say this yeah  that was the pr team definitely that was  like  um  you  you messed up girl  isn't it nice building your platform on  whatever the hell you want to talk about  so no one can cancel you  try